[Music]
good evening I'm Alexander rose on the
executive director here at the long now
foundation thank you for all squeezing
in a couple things about tonight as some
of you may realize there's 450 people in
this room and we built the interval so
that we could have receptions after
these talks and our fire marshal just
this week set our limit at 49 people so
one in ten of you are welcome at the
interval but we are actually having a
reception here in the lobby and we'll
have some communications back in fourth
we'll have wine and and beer here for
sale in the lobby and then the interval
will also be open all the way until
midnight green serves last table at
about 9:00 so if you do or set seats the
last table at about 9:00 so if you do
hang out for longer we'll try and
communicate when there's when there's
room but we do have to maintain a door
person at 49 people over there now fun
fun the other the other bit of news is
our long short so as some of you know
before these talks we have a short film
that exemplifies long-term thinking and
this months you know there's there's a
lot of things that could cross over the
creator' economy but this one short that
came out of London via Egypt by a person
who literally was building 3d printers
from Sun and sand and I think it's best
exemplifies the creator' economy enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey I'm Stuart and I have a cold we
realized that I might be able to stumble
through an introduction but matching
wits with our speaker and QA was
probably out of the question would
become a comedic episode so we cast
around for who might be a proper
Inquisitor for this speaker and we got a
volunteer tonight's your chance to have
your written question your provoking
question intoned by distinguished New
York Times journalist John Markoff John
probably won't mind if I mention that he
has a book coming out on robots and
robotics called machines of loving grace
and there will be an event about that at
the interval um I think in September or
so now economics ideally is a form of
long term thinking a rigorous form but
it seems to connect with people best
when it's matched with an
anthropological perspective and our
speaker tonight trained in anthropology
and he learned about long-term thinking
from his field study work in Mexico with
Mayans the Mayans had at the time of
Columbus's arrival on these continents a
more accurate calendar and a much longer
term calendar than anything Europeans
had or could imagine he and Markov go
back a long way so I think that will be
productive
whenever Markov needs a really pithy
quote for an article it needs a pithy
quote he calls Sappho and he gets one
that's gone on probably 40 or 50 times
at least and I expect we'll get more of
it tonight please welcome Paul Sappho
[Applause]
Thank You Stuart I'm sorry not to be
grilled by Stuart afterwards but also
it's I'm a little relieved
especially after I disguise frightening
how much he knows about my background
that I never talk about here's what I
want to do in in the next 45 minutes or
so is if you all remember the the next
economy the so called new economy of
1997 and 1999 well it's all arriving
late and in unexpected ways I think
we're in a phase transition state in the
economy and it started with riblets of
events about a hundred years ago but
really that stuff that started in the
90s is congealing in unexpected ways and
it's going to shape at least the next
half century of our economic landscape
it's you know at the highest level quite
simply what happens is we get a
technological innovation the media
innovation or the like and media
innovations lead to economic shifts in a
very specific way the new forms of media
technology appear new models emerge they
lead to entirely new kinds of products
both real and virtual and they end up
utterly changing how we live and work
quite simply as it's been observed first
we invent our technologies then we turn
around and we use our technologies to
reinvent ourselves as individuals as
communities and as entire societies and
we all have the good fortune to be at
ground zero of one of those quite
remarkable shifts and of course being in
the middle of it sometimes we forget
just how astonishing what it is so just
a comment about what I'm doing this is a
little different than many salt talks
I'm not here backed up by a book I'm
actually sharing some thoughts in
process some explorations I'm
and I'm gonna share what I've learned so
far in the spirit of provoking a
conversation and and also hoping to get
ideas and insights back as a consequence
now one rule I follow as a forecaster is
always look back twice as far as you're
looking forward as Mark Twain allegedly
said history doesn't repeat itself but
very often it rhymes and if you look
back at the earlier stuff you can get
real insights into what is happening to
today so I take you back to just before
1900 and this picture the worker in
front of a venn newfangled
time clock this picture I think
perfectly captures the essence of what
the emerging industrial economy was at
that moment in time it's important to
keep in mind that economies organized
around a challenge they often arise
around overcoming a skill overcoming a
scarcity and the scarcity in the early
days of the industrial economy was stuff
that the big challenge for the captains
of industry at the time was how to make
enough stuff cheaply enough to satisfy
the desires of an emergent middle-class
and and the working class who were
working in the factories and part of the
way they did it was to systematize
manufacturing the central actor was the
worker the woman here in front of the
time clock and for me the time clock was
a perfect symbol of the philosophy of
the time how to organize workers with
machine like efficiency in the service
of overcoming scarcity so jump ahead a
few years to Henry Ford here with a
Model T and from in 1908 1908 was the
year that automobiles took off on their
exponential upward climb and popularity
and and the Ford Model T was it was a
really important development there
because by 1914 an assembly line worker
on a Ford plant could afford to buy a
Model T with just four months salary
again make
enough stuff cheaply enough to meet the
demand demands of an emerging middle
class and by the way there's a wonderful
though slightly apocryphal story about
the Model T that captures this Henry
Ford once famously said you can have any
color Model T you want so long as it's
black and you ask yourself why did he
pick black well obviously you know roads
were not paved then things were very
dusty he obviously asked a software
engineer what the best color would be
well as the story goes they actually
very carefully chose black and they
tested it for just one thing and that
was how quickly the paint dried because
the faster the paint dried the faster
they could run the line the story is
slightly apocryphal but the essence is
true they were very very meticulous
about everything all the way down to the
kind of paint they chose in the service
of manufacturing efficiency so time goes
on the industrial captains of industry
the industrial economy get better and
better at making stuff and producing
more and more stuff until you know the
30s and the 40s and World War two
arrives and World War two was a moment
in time which was the apotheosis of the
industrial economy many brave people
fought and died on all sides of that
conflict but a key reason that World War
two was won by the Allies was because
the industrialist the time had got so
efficient at making stuff they were
capable of making more stuff than the
other side could blow up and the real
heroes of this apart from the people on
the front lines where were two
individuals one William Knutson here on
the cover of Time magazine he'd worked
for Henry Ford he had been head of GM's
Chrysler division and he at the start
just as we were mobilizing for World War
two came to Washington in Newark
organized the entire industrial process
Roosevelt called the arsenal of
democracy and I'll quote a passage of
Knutson at the time he said if we get
into the war the winning of it will be
purely a question of material and
production if we know how to get out
twice as much material as everyone else
and know how to get it and use it we are
going to come out on top and win as a
commentator at the time said England's
battles were won on the playing fields
of Eton America's will be won on the
assembly lines of Detroit and the
statistics of the time are astonishing
1941 1942 may the Battle of Midway the
turning point in the Pacific War America
went into that battle with three and a
half aircraft carriers in 1944 the
arsenal democracy was producing eight
aircraft carriers per month one plane
every 15 minutes a hundred fifty tons of
steel per minute 50 merchant ships per
day by the end of the war 70% of the
American economy was devoted to making
war material it was it was the triumph
of the industrial economy this obsession
with efficiency and mass production and
the like and there was a wrinkle because
when the war ended and the captains of
industry shifted back to making goods
for consumers they discovered or for
customers as they recalled it at the
time they discovered that the horror
they had become so efficient at making
stuff they were now capable of making
more stuff then people wanted to buy now
everyone expected a recession or a
depression after the war because that
was what was traditional when economies
retooled back to civilian activities in
fact there there was hardly a recession
because that moment was when the
industrial economy ended economies are
not done in by their success or done in
by their failures or the contradictions
there
and by their success they had met the
challenge they'd set out to meet in 1900
they had overcome scarcity and it turns
out in economies every new abundance
creates an adjacent scarcity and the
adjacent scarcity was no longer stuff it
was desire the missing piece the great
new challenge in the economy wasn't how
to make stuff to fulfill people's desire
but rather how to compel people to
desire the abundance people were capable
of making that was a moment the
industrial economy ended and the
consumer economy began and it was a
profound shift the new central actor in
this economy was no longer the work or
the person who produced but the consumer
the person who purchased and for me a
suitable symbol of that economy was what
was then quaintly called the charge card
in the 1930s and 40s but became the
credit card with the launch of the
BankAmericard and fresno in 1958 this is
the first modern credit card and it was
a vehicle for fulfilling desire even at
times when you might not actually have
the money so the consumer becomes the
center the worker becomes the supporter
the symbol they cut this new consumer
economy centered around desire is the
credit card and it was a shift in
management in the industrial economy
this was the person who was the center
of activity the VP of manufacturing in
the first half of the century they went
on to be the CEO along comes the
consumer economy in the 1950s the power
shifts to the VPS of sales and marketing
after 1955 if you wanted to be a CEO you
had to be in sales and marketing VPS of
manufacturing didn't disappear their job
was essential but no longer sufficient
you still had to make stuff but the
people in charge of creating desire were
the people who were in control of the
show now there's a third person in the
equation
I bought it will come back to her
because it turns out she becomes very
very important just a few years ago now
the other thing about this was an eerie
parallel today to today that TV was a
key enabler of this consumer economy it
arrives in the mid you know in 1951
the year that television takes off on
its curve perfect vehicle for creating
desire the symbol as seen on TV appeared
in magazines next to products because it
said this product was so important it
showed up on television that's why you
should buy it and you had stars
advertising all this stuff so it's all
about creating desire for stuff but not
just the old stuff I mean because after
everybody had a second refrigerator a
second car
how many cars and refrigerators did they
have it was about making desire for
entirely new kinds of things that never
existed before that never would have
made any sense without the sales and
marketing channels and things like
television earth-shaking things like the
veg-o-matic and this is actually my
bedroom attic and I actually bought it
on eBay here it is
first edition complete with the box and
extra trimmers and the like and it cost
me 15 bucks so think about that how many
veggie Mattox did they sell you know to
make them 15 bucks today 60 years after
the fact now the interesting thing to
think about is humankind has gone
through nearly 10,000 years of the urban
experiment without everybody waking up
in the morning and saying my life is
incomplete without a concertina slicer
and yet in a very short period of time
the power of the consumer economy caused
everybody every home in this country to
either go out and buy one of these
things or aspire to own one that's the
kind of pivot that was going on with the
consumer society so time goes on they
get better and better at creating desire
credit cards go deeper into our lives
they start changing environments they
change the retail environment the way
you get gas the way
way you interact with salespeople and
lichen and of course as time goes on we
become better and better at desiring
things we might not need can't use and
the like and it starts following a
trajectory a lot like the industrial
economy they were more efficient at
making stuff the consumer society was
more efficient than ever at creating
desire in consumers and so I thought
about what's a suitable symbol of the
consumer economy the television that's a
visible one you know maybe computers
later on no I think the right symbol of
the consumer economy is in this picture
it's it's not the boat it's the little
things on top Oh sh encanta neurs the
intermodal container first experimented
with in 1956 it became a standard in
1968 the year the first microprocessor
was was produced the four double-o 4
which is an interesting coincidence the
ISO standard intermodal container is a
perfect symbol of the consumer economy
because it represents the whole
reorganization of the marketing and
manufacturing and sales in the
fulfillment of desires the volume of
global trade doubled in the decade after
the introduction of the container in
1968 and it just keeps growing this
particular ship the oigan Maersk is is
an eClass container ship it's the
largest container ships on the ocean
today it holds for just under fourteen
thousand containers deadweight tons of a
hundred fifty six thousand tons it's
1,300 feet long and 180 feet wide it's
so big that of course it can't possibly
fit through the Panama Canal
that's why Nicaragua is building a
second canal through the the Isthmus
just so we can get our stuff more
quickly and cheaply so you might begin
to catch my drift here we start seeing
the consequences of success marketing
and sales convince a
every more to be more efficient you know
I desire more stuff collect more stuff
we all become like salmon swimming
upstream just instinctively buying more
stuff phrases like shop therapy come
into our our vocabulary so what we do we
got you know all this stuff we bought
with money we don't have well let's make
bigger houses to store more of the stuff
we've acquired and that worked here in
California for a while and then there
was a limit on that and and and people
had more stuff than they could store in
their houses so you know this is a
United States we're innovators we came
up with public storage YouTube for a
couple hundred bucks a month can store
all the crap you bought with money you
didn't have and things you can't use but
don't want to get rid of the only
problem is you got to drive it down
there and some people are too lazy to do
it well this is America we have a
solution for that pods on portable
on-demand
storage they drive it up to your
driveway they leave it there you fill it
up they take it off they store it and
then you pay your fee as a member of the
board and long now I keep thinking we're
missing an opportunity here that the
obvious long now solution to this is we
will buy a big piece of land out in the
Nevada desert not a mountain but a
valley we'll dig a big trench and we
will offer 10k storage and we'll have a
one-time fee the box will be filled up
we'll take it out there we'll lay it
down in stratigraphic order very
carefully covered up and leave a love
note to the archaeologists of 2200 ad
and say there are a whole bunch of
theses here and you know you can write
one dissertation after another and you
won't have to be sitting there with the
camels hair brush getting the stuff out
well it might have might guess by now I
I think that this reached its logical
conclusion and something had to break
and break it did and I know the exact
moment that the consumer economy ended
Friday November 17 2008
the market crash that was not just a
market crash that was a seam between two
economies the consumer economy was
doomed by its success in the same way
the producer economy was doomed by its
success the American consumer cried
uncle said we can't buy anything more
and it has now pushed us into an
entirely new and very strange an
unfamiliar economy the third person in
this equation is at the center of this
economy it's the consumer is turning
into something new the new scarce
resource is not stuff it's not desire
its engagement and the new central actor
in this economy are lots of terms
floating around my preferred term is the
creator
it's a create or economy not a creative
economy creatives or elites who hang
things on walls that we pay money for
know creators are ordinary individuals
like you and I who in the ordinary
course of our daily lives often think
we're consuming something and in fact
we're creating or consuming and creating
in the same single act bear with me I
know that sounds a little weird let me
give you a little more context this is
happened you know the the roots for this
now that we see it happening and the
roots are fairly deep this is a famous
quote by Herbert Simon in the 1970s what
information consumes is rather obvious
it consumes the attention of its
recipients hence a wealth of information
creates a poverty of attention some
people have called this the intention
economy other people want to call it the
engagement economy I just note that you
know the consumer economy was all about
creating desire we did not call it the
desire economy this is I hope to
demonstrate in a moment is about
engagement but I think it's really about
creation that's the most important thing
going on and by the way just as in the
1950s the arrival of TV in television
Titans like ABC NBC CBS fueled the
consumer economy you know these Titans
are sort of tottering these days you
know that's why it's mostly
tall ads on TV networks there's an
entirely new class of media Titans that
have appeared we've done this shift from
mass media to personal media and this is
all hugely obvious to everyone in this
room I and I would imagine some people
saying I came to hear this but let's
just pause and consider how truly
strange this shift has been imagine
sitting in this room in 1987 the year Al
Gore invented the internet and everybody
seriously it was the moment when all
this online stuff was sort of seeping
into the general consciousness and the
like and imagine saying to folks we are
just around the corner of this vast
media revolution this is going to just
blow the doors off of Hollywood and
everywhere else and completely changed
the global landscape and the like and
and they said what's it gonna be like
and you say well you know LexisNexis and
Lockheed dialogue you know those search
companies and there were really you know
sort of hot in 1987 they cost a lot of
money I still remember you getting
hauled into the dean's office at
Stanford because I ran up to big a lucky
dialogue bill I say well it's going to
be like that that what we're going to
have is this this wild notion of
hypertext is gonna appear in in less
than 10 years it's gonna sweep through
the terrain everybody is going to be
connected to this global hyper document
system and they said well what are we
gonna do watch movies and you know 500
channel universes no no the really hot
thing is going to be search that
everybody will be completely obsessed
with looking stuff up on the internet
and they so mean it's like an
encyclopedia
well yeah but more entertaining and and
and and it's like lucky dialog yeah but
it's free um but the biggest media
company in the world will be by the year
2000 will be a company that only offers
a search and it doesn't cost anything
they would have locked you up
as a dangerous crazy but if you had said
it then you'd get credit for predicting
the arrival of Google so you know we
have all these companies these new
personal media companies but one really
important thing about them is they
enable creation
you know before before Twitter if you
wanted to write a headline you had to
work for the New York Times before
YouTube if you wanted to put a movie on
a video on a screen you had to work for
a television network before before
Wikipedia if you wanted to write an
encyclopedia entry you had to work for
Encyclopedia Britannica or be a
certified smart person Nobel laureate
earth alike and then there's Google
Google is a really interesting one
because it captures the essence of the
creator' economy remember I said
sometimes we think we're consuming
information in fact we're creating it or
vice versa
all these things allow us to create
information but but just think for a
moment you know Google absolutely
essential tool in your lives and
probably used it in the last 24 hours
couldn't possibly live without it this
morning as I was working on my talk the
networked went down I live in comcast
territory and I couldn't get to Google
and-and-and-and so ask yourself what was
your Google subscription last month I
mean because didn't you pay Google
because of course Larry and Sergey are
both richer than God and yeah I didn't
pay anything well actually you pay we
just don't think we pay for Google
because the coin we pay with has no
value to us we want the answer we don't
care about our question Google wants the
question they want to just give you an
answer good enough to keep you coming
back that's the essence of the Google ad
revenue model that they aggregate our
questions the Creator economy in many
cases we are unwitting creators which by
the way you know whenever you encounter
a free service in the creator economy
it's like the line from that old movie
about Las Vegas you sit down at a
at a roulette or at a poker table what's
the first thing you do you look around
the table and you ask yourself who is
the sucker and if after looking around
the table you cannot identify who the
sucker is oh well what do you conclude
you are the sucker a key thing in the
creator economy is pay attention to when
you may be creating without realizing it
and whether you might be paying more
than you actually wish to pay for
something so the transitions are
everywhere
older folks in this room will remember
once upon a time when we used to just
watch movies you know now World of
Warcraft we play the movies we
participate in World of Warcraft is
ancient way back in 2004 and I'm
reminded constantly being on the
Stanford campus that nobody owns a
stereo anymore the days of listening to
music are long gone you know guitar hero
also ancient software we participate you
have to participate in the process and
create music so it sounds a little weird
and geeky and these look like geeky
things but let's stay for a moment on
video games video games are no curiosity
they're bigger than Hollywood lots
bigger than Hollywood so how many here
folks have played call the duty it's I
realize it a little really so how about
how about halo okay you know I think you
all need to get out more
let me give you some numbers here
November 2009 modern warfare 2 came out
it sold 310 million dollars of product
in 24 hours two weeks later
avatar the movie came out blockbuster it
only did 73 million in weekend sales
call of duty black ops in 2010 360
million in 24 hours in 2011 modern
warfare 3 400 million in 24 hours Harry
Potter's Deathly Hallows only did 483
million that weekend this is bigger than
Hollywood Lots
lots bigger and you know that's why you
have things like twitch you know imagine
you're a venture capitalist I come to
you I said got this really great idea
for a an interactive platform and I said
what was it do it lets people to sit at
their computers and watch other people
play video games would you invest in
that I certainly hope you would have
because twitch when it got sold to a
certain company in Seattle got sold for
just under 1 billion dollars this is a
huge shift now again thinking to me it's
an indicator immersion and participation
is the new normal this is about drawing
people in getting them engaged so
companies can capture their data streams
and engagement is not confined to gamers
it's mainstream I ask you how of course
Google is a very valuable business tool
how many of you have been sitting at
your desk you're bored you're waiting
for a conference call to begin and you
go to Google and you search cute cat
videos or Google's and entertainment
media but it's a funny sort of
entertainment medium you got to put
something in to get something out and
that's the pattern of the creator'
economy is a rebalancing you know in the
consumer economy we watched and we
bought in this new economy we
participate and we create and
participation like searching for cat
videos on Google is not an option if you
don't participate you don't have the
experience so let me pause and give you
the smartest advice that will give you
all evening read this article gentil
rolls platform competition and two-sided
markets now it always annoys me that the
Nobel Committee cannot seem to admit
that an American is capable of writing
something for the Nobel Prize in
Literature but they really got it right
when they gave Tirol and Roche the Nobel
Prize this is the article that explains
why your iPhone is so cheap and your
monthly bill is so expensive and
Facebook is free and I will probably get
into it in the Q&A but
trust me if you do nothing else read
this article because it really explains
some foundational dynamics of this
emerging consumer economy or creator
economy but meanwhile it's not just
electronics just like the consumer
economy changed retail the creator
economy is leaking out into the physical
world I took this picture on Market
Street recently in front of a GNC store
and for folks who don't know GNC they
sell bodybuilding powder and supplements
and as you can see I'm not a customer
but it's a pretty masculine store and it
struck my attention because it said I
mean forgive me if I fall into a
stereotype here but as a guy I shopped
the way a fox sneaks into a farmers yard
I want to get in get my product avoid
eye contact with a salesperson and get
out and you know maybe weekly smile and
say have a nice day or the like this is
no no no you know mr. bodybuilder pull
out your smartphone scan the QR code and
come in and hang out in our store and
engage and explore and look for
easter-egg deals in the like you know
retail is reinventing itself around
engagement happening everywhere here's a
recent announcement in The Chronicle
Target and Google they created a
shopping game at a Target store down in
in Sunnyvale the messages come play
while we track you and discover all of
your data streams and consumer
preferences you know aquella
unfortunately had to stop people playing
hide and seek in the aquella stores
recently but I'm sure it will reappear
as an app and you know once upon a time
with coffee you used to just buy coffee
and companies like Hills brothers worked
really hard to take all the little
coffee producers product and turn it
into this one consistent one size fits
all for everyone in the creator economy
were going away from consistency to
difference and to the story so this this
company feel-good Foods was sponsoring
the coffee break at a conference down at
singularity University for us
I was absolutely arrested by the signs
on the top because these you know signs
was they were telling me all the way
down you know except for the GPS
coordinates of the farms this came from
and Karis Steph and Jordan were really
eager to talk about the coffee it wasn't
just about the coffee it's about the
interaction that's about engagement not
just with the people behind the counter
but with the coffee growers whom you've
never met authenticity rules in this
world and engagement rules it is part of
the experience and of course we've seen
that go a step further this was a
picture I took a coab er 2013 at
Starbucks
you may remember Congress is having a
little dust-up then and Howard Schultz
said let's all come together let's let's
you know do acts of kindness so we did a
pay it forward thing at Starbucks and so
here I am at Starbucks you know I got my
morning run in and I'm racing out and
grabbing coffee on my way to campus I'm
still not quite awake and I get the
front and the barista says what would
you like and remember this is October
nowhere I said let's see venti soy decaf
peppermint no wit mocha now I'm just
proud of myself that I managed to get
all the way through that once without
screwing it up and then they say well
what would you like for your other
coffee and I go my other coffee you know
my spouse isn't here and and even though
this is my local Starbucks I don't
nobody else in here they said well you
have to get another coffee Anna and it
was quickly becoming apparent I wasn't
gonna get my coffee unless I got
somebody else coffee and so I turned to
the construction guy next to me he's on
his smartphone he's working up to the
College Sammy said dude what do you want
and he looks at me is it this odd hey
man I'm married you know I am not
hitting on you
I just want my coffee and so finally I
managed to get out of there well you
know obviously it was success because
here's my coffee cup from just about a
week and a half ago at Starbucks with
the race together thing that we're
supposed to have conversations about
race at the coffee and my my favorite
comments well I will put
but you know the point is once a ton of
time we just bought coffee now we have
to interact we it's about the story it's
about engagement and the like
I love these experiments and it's also
an indicator that we're still in the
early days of the creator' economy this
is like 1953-54 and the consumer economy
where all sorts of new ideas emerging
all sorts of wonderful creative
entrepreneurial things like what Howard
Schultz is doing even if he's a little
over the top at moments and nothing
quite makes sense but that it is a time
shot through with optimistic utopianism
that always happens in the early days
all revolutions begin with optimistic
utopianism like Burning Man
Burning Man really captures the creator
economy we all know the model no motto
no bystanders I mean and it's not that
you know the Blackrock Rangers come
around and enforce the no bystander rule
it's just you'd feel so uncomfortable if
you weren't a participant that you
wouldn't hang out again participation is
not an option it's an essential part of
the experience and the Maker Faire how
many people in this room remember being
teenagers and what was the last thing
you saw before you disassembled the
family's tape deck the little sign
warning do not open no user serviceable
parts inside well this is what we have
pushed our way into now is if you can't
open it you don't own it and everything
is about you know creation and coming up
with wonderful new ideas this is pretty
elite stuff I am going to omit the man
the the obviously mandatory 3d printing
slide at this point which also is an
evidence of the the touchingly utopian
moment today the essence of the create
or economy at this moment is a shift
when stuff was expensive stuff had
status today thanks to 3d printing and
and globalization and the like stuff
isn't expensive now stuff is cheap
creation has status the hottest devices
in our lives our device
that are vehicles for experience and
interaction you know smartphones the
selfie stick and the like so all great
stuff but there's an asterisks on this
revolution it's a hard lesson learned
from the dot-com revolution of the 90s
and the bubble you know remember that
touchingly naive optimistic period we
talked about this in cyberspace the
economy of gifts friction free
capitalism the final arrival of
telecommuting and the like and what we
got was you know spam the gig economy
and instead of cyberspace we got
suburbia so it's not all going to be
happy going forwards and with that in
mind let me offer four rules consider
these rules for revolutionaries and I
was thinking about they may actually
apply to the Arab Spring as well as
Silicon Valley rule one there are always
winners and losers rule two in a
revolution do not confuse the early
results with the long term outcome rule
three successful insurgents tend to
become over powerful incumbents and four
technologies of freedom inevitably
become technologies of control there is
a dark side to the creator economy but
the outcomes are negative outcomes are
not inevitable provided we are vigilant
and so what I want to do is close
covering four areas just a quick pass on
the implications of the creator' economy
for each I'll cover privacy ownership
work and freedom privacy Brandeis was
was right as I will explain in a moment
Justice Brandeis is famous comment that
privacy is the right to be left alone
but as a forecaster I spend a lot of
time looking for indicators weird things
that don't fit that go passing through
my life and way back in 2011 I had a
really weird experience I was cutting my
way across Red Square on my way to a
meeting
with some Russian officials and in the
middle of Red Square I just stopped and
and and almost collapsed in giggles
because I realized I was being
surveilled by the most advanced
surveillance at technology on the planet
and imagine if you went back to someone
in 1986 and said oh yeah you know in Red
Square and and was being tracked by
intelligent cameras and the like and
they were capitalist cameras the most
sophisticated camera in Red Square was
this thing the Google Street View
tricycle and I had a really nice
conversation with the Street View driver
was sitting there smoking a cigarette
but the thought that you know capitalist
cameras were out doing the former
communists right on Red Square was
arresting as it were and I know you know
we talk about privacy as a right well
privacy seems to be a pure right a long
time ago and it was well before the
creator' economy that we paid for
privacy you paid extra for an unlisted
phone number paid extra for a frequent
buyer card
well now the create or economy and all
the technologies lining up make the
collection of the data streams coming
off of us so much easier it's more
desired by companies it's more valuable
and therefore it's more costly to get
out of the data stream and try and
recover your privacy and more expensive
I was a member of 18 T's Technology
Board in the 1990s so I tend to follow
what they do and this I just love that
they have announced a new pricing for
the ATT universe Giga power plan
it costs a hundred ten dollars a month
or a hundred thirty nine dollars a month
if you want to preserve your or preserve
your privacy one hundred ten bucks a
month such a deal but you give them your
data stream remember don't give away
something that's more valuable than you
realize quite simply what it is in the
Creator economy is we've all become like
tassel tassel is a wonderful polar bear
at the Oregon Zoo she as you see is
wearing a tagger
around her her neck I mean we're all
just like tag bears you know they're not
tassel no no darts were used on tousle
but if air is walking through the woods
and suddenly feel something hit it and
it wakes up with a headache and a radio
collar around its neck well the only
reason Facebook and Google and Twitter
and all the rest of them don't shoot
darts at us is that we put the radio
collars on ourselves
they're called smart phones you know
think about all the data streams coming
off this thing even when you know you're
not using it we happily surrender our
privacy for convenience and eventually
we're going to end up buying it back in
real time by the way tassel is more like
us than I admit that I'm told she's very
happy to let them put the collar on and
it has a camera on it so if you go to
the Oregon Zoo website that you can see
tassels real-time bear cam view as she's
walking around the yard um sounds kind
of interesting well you know that's
meerkat periscope you to and and and
like like us tassel has a very nice
designer designer radio collar god
forbid that it's in the color that
clashed with referred well consider
Google Street Google Maps you know try
turning off your location service on
your smartphone and the inconvenience
you have with Google Maps you pay for
privacy you pay with inconvenience and
Street View entices us to allow Google
to track us I love this you know they
they go down through Barrier Reef's that
went down to Colorado in 2013 you can
see the street view cam on the top of it
and allows all of us who've never you
know rafted the Colorado to raft down
without getting wet and have the
experience while we're amusing ourselves
before a phone call talks remember as a
forecaster I look for indicators this
picture has an interesting clue that we
have not yet entirely surrendered to
being passive sources of data streams
for companies at least some of us are
not going down without a fight so the
center picture you can kind of see
something on the beach there it's a
little heart
to see let me show you the close-up
[Laughter]
this was the rafters response to the
arrival of street view on the Colorado
River it's amusing but let us face it
resistances feeble and futile because
the economic forces compelling
engagement and participation are
overwhelming
this protest marvelous as it was was
quickly reduced to performance art
recorded by the very object to protest
to be discovered by a bored user like me
you know we'll keep trying this is a
picture actually shot in nineteen eighty
nine little brother keeps trying to look
back but it is a rearguard action and
honestly it's a rearguard action against
ourselves because of course we're gonna
trade convenience with the desire for
privacy is that famous Pogo cartoon one
of Walt Kelly's had we have met the
enemy and he is us we are willing
co-conspirators in this creator economy
the most we can hope for is to go back
to brand Isis observation in 1890 at the
time objecting to newspapers that
privacy was the right to be let alone I
hope that is the firewall that we will
go forward on the second issue ownership
your data or your money is really what
it comes down to you of course don't own
your smartphone you subscribe to it try
using the smartphone without the service
it's just that the phone companies are
so screwed up they charge you for it as
well as charging you monthly everything
coming into our lives today has digital
strings attached
it is becoming a world of partial
partial conditional ownership own a
Prius don't own the battery cable box
don't own that either but you need it
and of course your smartphone you don't
exactly own that either and it'll get
worse here's the Google self-driving car
on highway 280 and
they will arrive they'll arrive sooner
than people realize self-driving cars
are coming fast
we will never own self-driving cars we
will subscribe to self-driving cars in a
robotic version of uber over the like
some people law them only the very rich
will own them they will do so either
because they want to buy the privacy or
to satisfy their ego of having a large
expensive object that they only
occasionally use us most of us will be
riding around in in shared vehicles that
you know when if Google ever gets into
the business or the intersection of car
share or uber with this you know I did I
know exactly what it looked like the car
you call it up the robotic car will show
up your door you'll get in it they will
capture where you started where you
ended up they will have street view
cameras on the side of the car taking
pictures as it goes so you'll be an
unpaid Street View driver and that I
have a camera inside tracking your iris
movement noting what advertisements you
find of interest on the way so they can
serve it up to you when you get back to
your desk you know more proof
it is simply Google's world we happen to
live in it so that's the kind of world
we're in and the way you opt out we will
own less and less we will subscribe to
more and more we will have access and we
will pay and we will pay and we'll pay
because as things are free for a while
then we start to get charged and it's
already happening third area work this
is a cover of a magazine from 1931 the
technocrats magazine that I have in my
library it is very fashionable at the
moment to fret about robots stealing our
jobs it is fashionable but beside the
point now on the surface the crater
economy looks like it's creating jobs
you know Mechanical Turk Kaggle ways
Airbnb think of all the people making
money with these things
let's take cattle how many people in
this room are familiar with cattle good
so for the rest of you cattle is a
crowd-sourced
data analytics company basically what
they do is it's predictive modeling and
you you join Kaggle as a member and they
have client sponsors who have questions
they want answer and they're set up as
prizes so they have competitions to see
who could who could win the price and in
2011 Allstate came to them and they said
yeah we want to do an experiment with
this and it said you know our crown
jewels at Allstate is our claims
algorithm it determines how risky a
potential customer could be we've
optimized it over the last 60 years
generations of actuaries and data
Sciences we haven't buffed up to a high
polish you know if you can improve it by
one or two percent we'll give a $10,000
prize so they put out the prize they say
you know it's a three-month competition
110 teams 200 plus experts and they come
back to Allstate at the end and they
said we're really sorry we did not
achieve a 2% increase all seasons no
problem you know it's a good experiment
and like I said no no no you still got
to pay so why do we gotta pay he said
you didn't get 2% the winning team
improved her algorithm by 271 percent
now that sounds like really happy news
that's like wow you know we you know
data scientist geek jobs everywhere well
think about all the actuaries at at
Allstate who probably got laid off after
that you know we're taking the job
relationship and we're breaking it up
into pieces you know we're peeling off
healthcare we're peeling off expectation
the retirement think of how many
so-called contractors in Silicon Valley
work longer hours than the few employees
left and the ones that we're not losing
that way because of the creator' economy
well basically I'll give you an example
here's a piece of spam I got yesterday
and I went oh this is perfect normally I
just thought wise men are you on
Facebook if you are I'm sure you already
have what it takes to like share and
comment every day people like you and I
are cashing in I didn't check to see how
much money I would be paid but part of
what's going on in the career
economy is we're atomizing our jobs out
of existence by you know have it's it's
not the jobs that are being taken by
algorithms and robots
it's the jobs that were never created to
begin with because they're done by
machines you know Facebook may be free
but has been observed we're not
Facebook's customers
we're Facebook's product this is
unwilling unwitting creation and you
know think about when you do something
like Kaggle or TaskRabbit or the like
you know who you may be creating a job
but who is losing their job you know in
a way is is this a moment when we're
outsourcing our own job to our neighbors
for less money and they're doing the
same thing to us lots of odd
contradictions here you know during in
the Creator in the in the in the
producer economy patriotic Americans in
World War one and two rationed and and
recycled during the Vietnam War in the
consumer economy when the scarce thing
was desired everybody joke said the last
thing you want to do is rationed by more
it's the vine that supports the war and
here we are into these funny little
situations where everything seems to be
just the the option opposite of what we
expect so the last one is freedom you
know on the surface you might say uh
sounds like a pretty pessimistic
observation we're happily trading our
freedom for our convenience you know we
want our privacy but please don't turn
off my location on my smartphone because
you know I absolutely need to know where
I am going well I think this is a moment
in a moment in fact when we are all
struggling to coexist with each other we
now have to learn how to coexist with
snoopy algorithms and robots invading
every corner of our lives
I'm actually an optimist I think the
secret is interdependence maybe all of
this complexification at the landscape
this spirit
of creation withing an unwitting the
conversate knowing where your coffee
comes from the like is going to finally
help us appreciate interdependence now
close with some wisdom from a poet here
in San Francisco in 1967 who put it very
nicely in this poem watched all watched
over by machines of loving grace if you
read that last last stanza I like to
think of a cybernetic ecology where we
are free of our labors and join back to
nature return to our brothers and
sisters and all watched over by machines
of loving grace well in a world where
privacy is now the right to be left
alone and hopefully robots do take our
jobs but we all get to continue to
create maybe we will discover
interdependence and maybe just maybe
that the most important short-term thing
to come out of this emerging creator or
economy that will shape the next half
century is an appreciation thanks to the
data streams of just how deeply we all
are connected to each other thank you
so be someone up John I'll bring my
bedroom attic in case we need to chop
something you can get those Incirlik
table these days - yeah no it's they do
have those fancy new ones but by the way
on this bedroom attic look up Ron
Coquille the founder of Ron Co the
essence of the veg-o-matic was you
couldn't have sold it before the
television arrived you know if you walk
past it on a shelf you've either say
it's useless or dangerous or both but it
was that constant reminder on TV the
awakening of desire it slices it dices
and wait there's more I think one of the
biggest consumer lessons I ever learned
was from a senior executive at Procter
and Gamble and we were talking about
toothpaste and and I said asking a
question he says no no you don't
understand
no entirely new product has ever
succeeded in the marketplace without
first offering the prospect of a
life-changing experience fluoride in
toothpaste that's why they had the
couple running down the beach into each
others arms it wasn't about white teeth
it was about all the wonderful things
that would come to you if your teeth
were just a little bit whiter and
they're still selling that today so
Stuart noted that I was one of those
people who quoted Paul perhaps too much
which I plead guilty to and there's a
reason why and that his reporters are
suckers for people who give good quotes
and there was a period during the PC era
and thereafter where I quoted Paul a lot
I have one story before I ask questions
and because Paul literally gave me the
best pull quote of my career and and
this was this story that was we're done
this is not as I said just one story so
this was the Week in Review section I I
wrote a story before the web on the rise
of keyboard sex and I called Paul up to
say you know what do you think about
this and without missing a beat he said
you know there's a lot of heavy clicking
going on out there
you can't pay for stuff like that so you
know we could do it over to the interval
now stop all this you know the other
great thing about being around Paul is
is you have lots of great field trips
with from being around Paul I've I've
landed on aircraft carriers with Paul
we've we've followed a constant we did
take off yeah yeah that's true we did
that's right in that Cod and we've done
autonomous car things Paul helped me
find the Google car we broke the story
of the Google car together which was
hiding in plain sight for a year before
anybody noticed it actually driving on
California freeways so we've had it and
as a as a forecaster the way I noticed
it was I mean look for things that don't
fit our nature is to just look you know
for things we expect anytime you see
something you don't expect take a note
of it I always have a pocket camera a
real camera not this dopey camera on my
smartphone and I had a paper like I was
going down to 80 at one point and I
noticed the oddest thing
there was a Prius that was actually
going the speed limit on 280 the Highway
Patrol gives you a ticket if you're
going less you know if you're going less
than 80 and and then I noticed there was
a bump on the roof and I thought yeah it
doesn't quite look like a street view
camera and and I went huh that looks
like a Valentine Center and and we had
lost a professor Sebastian Thrun who had
been ahead of our AI lab at Stanford he
disappeared to Google and so kind of
worried with so I pull up on the
driver's side and the drivers not
touching the wheel and I slow down and
go back to the other side the passenger
side there's a geek boy with a laptop
and I think son of a gun Sebastian's
running robots in the wild and
and and and and I called up John and
he'd already he said oh yeah
you found out about at a cocktail party
that's right why my the way the story
came to be was my cousin's son had a
friend in high school who mentioned to
him that he was being paid $15 an hour
by Google for sitting in cars but not
driving them we put two and two together
yeah
so let me ask you a little bit about
method because you've sit somewhere
between social scientists and
journalists you're neither
what's a forecaster and how do you do
what you do and why is it different than
what social scientists and journalists
do I actually I think more that I'm
living on the ragged edge between the
qualitative and the quantitative there
are times I have I just finished the
quarter at Stanford and just finished
reading student papers so I have to kind
of back out this out a little bit but
that is a forecaster it's part
anthropologist part sociologist a lot of
historian of Technology and lots of
different lots of different things but
the way I think of it is as I said
earlier looking for things that don't
fit you know Bill Gibson famously said
the futures already arrived it's just
not evenly distributed yet and those
things that don't fit her a little bit
like threads hanging down from the
future and so the essence of forecasting
at least the way I do it there's method
there's a formal method to my madness I
have a whole set of heuristics I follow
but what the method is is a discipline
it's a frame of mind I mean some of the
methods are very formal I just left the
company i co-founded four years ago we
were doing big data analytics
forecasting for Wall Street but for the
most part forecasting is applied common
sense I'll just give you one one example
that the point of method in forecasting
so whether it's like scenario analysis
Peter Schwartz
manaus the master of scenarios and like
or some other method you rely on method
so you know that moment when your
instinct well the point of method is to
get you to a point of robust intuition
trustworthy robust intuition where you
have a sense of what's going on and you
know you can act on incomplete
information with with conviction and the
method helps you in those situations
where instinct tells you one thing and
the method tells you the other it's a
little bit like driving a car on an icy
road you know the car starts to spin
Newtonian physics tells you one thing to
turn with the spin and your lizard brain
is screaming the opposite turn you know
against the spin and if you follow your
brain you're gonna follow hit the tree
and if you listen to Newton you'll do
just fine well the essence of
forecasting casting method is to give
you the tools to avoid hitting the tree
and get a further sense of what's down
the road so a couple of data points does
that vague enough for you well let me
let me sort of pursue this a little bit
with just to complicate a class so
there's a lot of discussion that we're
you know and some kind of a bubble again
and I just was struck with something
today and I wanted to ask you to sort of
interpret it because I remember that
Kara Swisher at the Wall Street Journal
started a column called boomtown shortly
before the dot-com collapse it might
have been a couple of weeks and I always
thought that was really ironic and I
went to KQED z-- website today and I
discovered that they've created a column
called boomtown Wells here and I thought
that can't be good
where are we are we are we in a
situation 15 years ago this is not like
the dot-com bubble that for starters
there take any one company and there is
lots of substance behind it during
the.com bubble
clueless and investment professionals on
Wall Street and the general public were
investing in companies with shaky models
like pets.com Jeff Bezos just paid a
billion dollars for twitch that company
that allows people to watch other plays
video games Jeff Bezos is a very stark
strategist he did not pay too much for
twitch so it's not like there's nothing
there it's also not a bubble for another
reason in that the public doesn't get to
participate in this you know the biggest
problem in Silicon Valley at today with
this bubble for example who here got to
invest in YouTube when they went public
that'd be nobody because they are
acquired by Google the number of
companies going public and actually
being accessible to ordinary citizens to
be able to invest in is shrinking and
that I think is going to [ __ ] things
that part is is a problem but I tell you
story about bubbles in Silicon Valley
there was one time I was having
breakfast in Cupertino with the guy who
just stepped down as the head of one of
our biggest most important companies in
Silicon Valley and we were having
breakfast at the Good Earth and he said
you know I've had it with this place
it's too crowded houses cost too much
the traffic's terrible you can't get
anywhere it's got to be over that
Silicon Valley has hit the end well his
name was Jack Tramiel
he was the head of Atari and this was
around 1986 there are some reasons why
Silicon Valley will as well resilience I
read a book called the high cost of high
tech and then 85 how'd that work out the
valley is very resilient well was a good
book that was about the high social cost
yeah so but I mean I just got a press
for a product that sole feature was it
was a vodka
that was Bluetooth programmable with an
LED and I guess you can get it at Costco
I didn't know that but but I'll show you
yeah it's a first edition I mean is that
any easier than what we saw earlier so I
was at a meet-up in Sunnyvale last week
and there's a transportation planner who
said 2020 is the year that 101 breaks
and I was thinking about that when you
when you when you we're talking about
self-driving cars do they solve the
problem you know ownership or not
ownership of self-driving cars so they
solved the problem of Transportation
well you talked to all the self-driving
car gurus Sebastian and and the others
they say look you know you could put
think about the the to it you you all
I'm sure follow the two and a half
second rule which is you count one one
thousand two one thousand that's the
distance you should be in front of the
car in front of you right raise your
hands
well the freeway even when it's crowded
unless the traffic's actually stopped is
mostly empty and robots could ride six
inches off each other's bumpers but as a
forecaster the other piece of data I
would add to this there's a really
interesting transportation researcher at
the University of Michigan who has come
out with data and said that the year of
peak automobile was actually three years
ago that the number of miles being
driven by Americans is decreasing gas
consumes decreasing obviously miles
being driven number of cars being
purchased that we probably have already
past the peak okay
I've more questions but I'll start to
weave in our questions from the audience
because we have more questions in time
do I read people's names as part of the
question yes yes okay this is from Kelly
our book maybe it's Arbuckle yeah
if economies end upon achievement of
success what does success look like in
the creator' economy Thanks yeah I it's
a laser
it is the question and and thank you for
asking it even though I don't have a
decent answer as I said at the start I'm
sharing stuff I'm in the process of
thinking through because I know I'll get
ideas back my hunch is I mean think
about and I don't mean to pick on Google
I I really like Google as a company and
like but you know why did Google get
into Street View well their model was
built on us typing in information for
free and the problem with that is we
could only type so fast and we had to
sleep and do other things and so they
then expanded it to the rest of the
world and so will you type in for us too
and then they pretty much saturated the
planet and and then they really human
czar not reproducing fast enough to
support the Google model and so you said
well we need the data streams off their
devices so let's give them Street View
and then their phones will always give
us data and let's do robotic cars and
we'll get the data from that so I think
what this ends up becoming is is a you
know very well how many people have a
nest thermostat I do you know we all do
you know now you know people get to
figure out they can crack and thing
figure out when you're not home and know
when to rob you that that thing is
thinking all the time you do that from
the Dropcam what do they need oh yeah I
mean good god showed on I mean your
house will end up becoming a big data
stream so we have a while to run before
that gets saturated but I think that's
what becomes overabundant is is the data
part and the short term is the new
scarcity is is actually algorithms and
processing so this is gonna push push
the computer industry this is what's
going to create the demand for quantum
computers if we ever are lucky to
actually build one and the like so this
is this is a this is a good follow-on
from a Manuel Manuel meta does the
create or economy exacerbate income
equality and how do you combat that
because it absolutely exacerbates income
inequality absolutely the good news is
where we are solving global poverty the
bad news is that the gap between the
richest and the poorest is only going to
increase the companies that are getting
biggest are the ones who harness the
smallest quantum of information so
everybody here uses Google but you know
they're probably five people in your
who've actually written a Wikipedia
entry
that's why Wikipedia is a not-for-profit
and Facebook's wildly profitable the
companies that can are the best at
aggregating the information are the ones
who will grow the fastest and I also
I'll offer a forecast I remember
visiting Facebook two days before they
went public and they had just walked
moved into a new campus I was meeting
some of the executives and after mediums
are saying you want to walk around we
walk around campus it was empty
you could have shot a cannon down the
center of that campus and not hit a
person and I thought well you know it's
space for growth that is way too empty
and so I think about Facebook they had
done three point seven billion dollars
profit the year before our gross a
billion dollars profit they accounted
for more more traffic on the internet
than Google they were growing at this
outlandish number of users per day
and at the time they went public they
had a total of 2,400 employees go
Facebook at the time was not a company
Facebook was a machine it was a computer
that hired a couple of people to
figuratively walk around the walls halls
and make sure the plugs didn't fall out
of the wall is depriving the computers
so are you forecasting a people free
economy or is it so much work I I think
it's just it's sooner than we realize we
will have a company go public on the
stock exchange or get acquired that you
know there's a CEO and a bunch of algos
people but and the con that leads to
concentration of power and concentration
of wealth I mean
it's it I think the pull away of the one
you know the point a 1% is is going to
accelerate and what do we do for a
livelihood well there's a wonderful
story in in the nineteen well you tell
the story oh dear
General Motors head of the Union oh no
no yes well it was at GMOs Ford I think
and going to Ruth Gehrig Ruth are
getting the 250s and the the guy who was
to give him the tumor was showing him
these fancy robots and he sort of turned
to him and teased him and said you know
how are these robots gonna pay union
dues and ruther looks back and says how
are they going to buy cars no I think
we're headed the the future the people
are really missing the point on this our
robots stealing our jobs the whole idea
is like a comet on some loopy orbit that
shows up about every 20 years in the
1930s it was the technocrats in the
1960s there were people in very smart
people these sociologists Daniel Bell
was saying robots would replace work by
the mid-1980s and the great social
challenge would be what to do with all
our spare time and he posited the
leisure society I don't know about you
but I can't wait that I think we're in
for a very turbulent period and I think
one of the first consequences is we've
already unlocked the job relationship
into pieces
think about the contradictions that have
happened in earlier economies I think
the most interesting account of the
contradiction is going to be that people
realize are going to have to pay people
even if they don't work so pay close
attention to the universal basic income
movement this idea of you pay someone a
salary even if they don't work sounds
outlandish sounds absolutely outrageous
until you look into it and then you
discover economists on the left think it
was a great idea economists on the right
Milton Friedman thought it was a great
idea there's some very interesting
experiments Nixon proposed it and we did
yeah I mean let's not mention it I
actually think
we'll see that start to happen that
because of concentration of wealth
people realize they have to pay
universal basic income it's not welfare
we don't have time to talk about it here
it is absolutely intriguing and worth
looking into I'm not predicting the
specifics but I would be astonished if
this isn't taken up very soon there's
been some fascinating experiments in
some Indian states where they've created
these economies and in fact all those
measures where people are supposed to
come late become lazy that doesn't
happen right there was there was a
really successful experiment in Denmark
but you know how can you generalize
Denmark to anywhere else you know but
the experiments in India they they had
one very large-scale experiment where in
the village they gave everybody this
income and all the way including the
kids with no strings attached and then
they had other villages where they did
something more like traditional aid and
what they discovered one people didn't
get lazy like in Denmark people were
doing all sorts of wonderful artistic
things and in India they discovered the
more constraints they put on it the less
value they got out of the money just
given the money and letting them do it
allowed creative things to flourish it
along those lines okay just one thought
where we end up here I have my belief is
that at the end of the day this is about
stories you know far as I can tell
there's three things that motivate
people the desire to be useful the
desire to tell stories and the desire to
collect stuff we're back to pods
and I really think that at the end of
the day it's it's it's that the creator
economy is about stories that's what all
this experience is that's why
selfie-stick sirs being banned
everywhere
so Kevin Kelly has a question on that
what are the prospect for professional
creators is there a business model to
support full time creation and mastery
of a media well you know we have seen
ironically the wipeouts of creatives
because of Technology you know I have a
good friend who for 20 years made a very
profitable business selling stock photos
and his business died in less than six
months and we see that a lot of
professionals find far I think that this
is very much a star-making machine for
professional creatives it's opening up
the doors the good news about ordinary
creators is among them are extraordinary
people we don't know about like people
in the middle of the desert burning
burning sand into a glass bowl halo how
many people here know who Justin DC's
raise your hands one maybe if I tell you
his halo handle it's Justin I got your
pistola DS Justin Justin became a
professional he was serious Halo gamer
he became a professional Halo gamer at
17 and by October 2013 at the world Halo
Championships where he won seventy
thousand dollars in winnings he had
earned a quarter million dollars in halo
competition winnings before he turned 20
so star making machine
plenty of room for creators to move up
and become professional creatives it may
not be stable but it'll be hugely
entertaining
[Laughter]
Donna Teresa from livestream regarding
scarcity driving an economy considering
the wage gap between rich middle class
working poor
what would an alternative barter or non
government back currency economy look
like in the US sometime in the next 100
years
eg Bitcoin boy come up to me afterwards
a team of 5 students in my class just
did a forecast of where Bitcoin will go
my short-term take is don't confuse
Bitcoin with cryptocurrency that bitcoin
is the first crypto currency good enough
to be criticized and cryptocurrency is
hugely destabilizing it may be what
finally pushes the tottering
nation-state order into real chaos so
we're back to method from Matthew
Rudolph what are the best arguments
against the practice of forecasting and
the best arguments like so Vegas in
favor of it so defend defend and
criticize your art Oh God
well first of all the let me let me
answer it by explaining what the point
of forecasting is the point of
forecasting is not to predict the future
you know as as our famous philosopher
Yogi Berra said predictions really
difficult especially when it's about the
future it's not just that prediction is
difficult it's actually logically
impossible unless you're a
fundamentalist religious type who
believes God has a plan it's all
preordained but why bother to look at
you can't change the outcome
my intellectual posture is or our
actions in the present affect outcomes
in the future so the act of forecasting
isn't predicting a specific outcome it's
mapping a cone of uncertainty that
extends out from the present it's saying
how broad is that cone how much
uncertainty is there what are the things
that define the edges of that gun broad
narrow what are the possible paths
outwards and what are the
Insights I can take to make intelligent
action in the present that affects the
outcome so for me as a forecaster I you
know I I'm I'm wrong at least six times
before breakfast and and I've been wrong
plenty of times and I I often get lots
of credit for things that I really
didn't say like a Wired magazine I did
an article I think in 94 titled it's the
context stupid and and you know if
you're vague enough in your forecast
everybody thinks you're genius I said
the future belongs not to the content
providers but the companies that that
sort and search and everybody says I
predicted Google I had no idea Google as
Annika but I'm wrong so much of the time
I'll take it
so being wrong isn't the problem the
ones that hurt is when you're right and
you can't and you didn't effectively
communicate it to someone to make the
right actually that's that's what hurts
but at the end of the day forecasting is
systematically applied common-sense
everybody should be doing it don't
listen to actors oh one other thought
default the default posture if you're
ever asked about something offer a
pessimistic forecast okay almost beep
estimate because we offer an optimistic
if you offer a pessimistic forecast and
it comes to pass everybody think you're
a genius and I won't mention the names
of people that this works very well for
if the forecast doesn't come to pass
they'll forgotten you made the forecast
and so you won't get dinged but if you
offer an optimistic forecast and it
doesn't come to pass they'll be really
ticked off at you and they'll almost
remember that so just default this if
you don't know what's ahead say
something pessimistic it's nine o'clock
and one last quick question from Andy
Lee what comes after the creator'
economy
yeah Oh God that's Bravo John is the
office ask one question too many I mean
honestly I don't know I'm still trying
to make sense of this thing and if I'm
right it's about thirty years thirty
years off but I think it is the the
amalgam of robots you know and and and
and an economy that is an automated
economy that it is is doing a lot of
things itself think of the World Wide
Web
today I mean how many people today read
an article that wasn't written by a
human
you all did if you read something on the
web today chances are you read something
but there's this whole other part of the
read it is producing data that's only
read by other robots and that part of
the web is actually bigger than the part
of the web that that we access so I
don't know if these super intelligent
robots will ever arrive you know the
ones that are evolving faster than us
and smarter than us but I am on record
is with a forecast of the outcome if
that does happen if super intelligent
super fast evolving robots should arrive
if we're very very lucky they will treat
us like pets it's and if we are very
very unlucky they will treat us like
food and on that note let's please give
Paula Han thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you